hallo ihr lieben ich lass euch gleich
ins video muss ich aber jetzt vorher die
big news erzählen und zwar gibt es meine
kiki scream das ist einmal die harte
riffs creme und die schokohasen ab
morgen in allen kaufland filialen
deutschlandweit
allerdings nur solange der vorrat reicht
dem ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schnell
sein und um 20 uhr gibt es noch eine
überraschung auf dem kanal das video
müsst euch unbedingt angucken ich bin so
gespannt was ihr dazu sagt und ansonsten
wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
für mein rezept
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es endlich
ist mir bombast für alle die es nicht
kennen das ist ein türkisches rezept und
ihr fraglich locker seit 34 jahren wann
machst du izmir baumasse das ding ist
ihr müsste ich wohl schon das ist so ein
rezept ich kann sich hier mal zeigen das
ist ein rezept darf den ganz dünnen
knusprigen teig und in drin hat sie dann
einfach so eine richtig leckere
schokocreme oder auch eine haselnuss
creme und die letzten jahre gemeinde
hasel system bietet seit einem jahr und
letzten habe ich mich dagegen gewehrt
weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen beißt so
richtig auf die creme und die muss
natürlich lecker sein so was bietet sich
also besseres ein als das rezept die
jetzt zu dem zeitpunkt zu machen wo ist
meine harte nuss meine schokocreme gibt
und findet ihn richtig gut aus und das
ding ist haben sie es gar nicht da
hinter der kamera ist nämlich sarah und
den test mache ich am ende mit hamza
borns im lager im shop der haben sie es
nämlich im job oder fahren am ende des
videos machen aber ich zeige ich jetzt
erstmal wie diese so leckeren dinge
funktionieren und ich gern mit inzest
macht wir starten jetzt mit dem fünf
minuten takt ist so easy leute ich gehe
jetzt direkt mein mail in die große
schüssel natürlich könnt ihr auch eure
küchenmaschine dafür verwenden aber
dadurch dass es so schnell geht und ein
besseres gefühl hat mit den händen mach
das jetzt mit den sauberen fingern da
gebe ich ein bisschen zucker dazu
vanille extrakt finde ich einfach jetzt
für den geschmack ganz nett und dann
kommt da noch lauwarmes wasser und
neutrales öl mit rein und dann einfach
alles miteinander verkneten
[Musik]
was hat jetzt keine drei minuten
gedauert habe auf der arbeitsfläche noch
mal ein bisschen weiter geknetet und
hier jetzt folgendes vor ist die
baumasse ist eigentlich wirklich nur so
dieser helle tiger wir machen jetzt auch
noch einen schoko teig dafür teile ich
den jetzt einmal in der hälfte durch der
eine darf er ruhig hell bleiben das
heißt er ist fertig man sieht auch
richtig schön wie vanille pünktchen
so und den einen teil gebe ich jetzt
hier schon mal in die schüssel wenn ich
gleich auch noch mal abdecken und dann
darf der schon mal gehen gehzeit beträgt
nur 20 bis 25 minuten da muss einfach
nur elastischer werden um für den schoko
teig nehmen wir uns jetzt ganz einfach
kakao und weil der sich also schlechter
rein verarbeitete ist schon wieder
trocken also erst mit liebe ich den das
ist ganz wichtig und dann nehme ich mir
noch mal so ein bisschen was vom öl dazu
in die hände und kriege das dann an
[Musik]
ich glaube ich las den teig sogar so
dass hat so ein bisschen diesen effekt
entweder sitzen nach dem backen nicht
gut aus oder das sind richtig richtig
gut lasst uns einfach mal überraschen so
zwischendurch zu experimente auch immer
ganz cool jetzt gebe ich ihm auch noch
mal hin die schüssel so ein bisschen
mehr rein und dann nach 20 minuten
machen wir weiter das rezept es übrigens
wirklich ein witz rezept
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unsere tage konnten jetzt richtig gut
entspannen dadurch werden sie elastisch
sie werden nicht aufgehen mir auch kein
keine hefe oder so was da drinnen daher
nicht wundern
und jetzt einfach auf der arbeitsfläche
so ein bisschen zu einer langen wurst
raus rollen und dann werden wir sie zu
kleinen kugeln formen
[Musik]
so die teiglinge könnt ihr jetzt schon
mal zu kugeln rollen dann habt ihr
gleich einfach so ein glattes und
schöneres ergebnis ist mache ich jetzt
gleich auch und die kleben auch nicht an
der arbeitsfläche also wenn überhaupt
nur so ein bisschen aber dadurch dass
wir das fett drin haben ist es
eigentlich gar kein problem er braucht
doch kein zusätzliches mail sondern es
werden sie euch noch zu trocken was ich
auch gemacht habe ich habe meine
haselnuss können das wirklich meine
füllung sein ich nehme meine reiner
haase muslim und meine haselnuss
schokocreme nicht zum befüllen und die
habe ich eine stunde zuvor den
kühlschrank getan wenn ihr sie auf
zimmertemperatur lagert was wir
eigentlich immer machen sollte ist sie
so wie es auf der verpackung steht
unendlich creme ich hab das sieht man ja
auch ganz gut und wenn ihr den
kühlschrank gibt ist einfacher für uns
zum verarbeiten denn dann wird sie so
ein bisschen fest da so wie man hier
sehen kann und so brauchen wir sie
können natürlich auch anders darum
machen aber so vereinfacht ihr euch die
ganze sache einfach jetzt werde ich die
teiglinge dünn ausbreiten entweder mit
den fingern noch besser mit seinem aus
rolf starb und dann in die mitte also
ungefähr eineinhalb bis maximal zwei
teelöffel von der haselnuss klemm rhein
geben
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die spitze
noch abschneiden damit den ich so viel
teig untendrunter habt falls ihr das
schon richtig einschätzte müsst ihr auch
nichts von wegschneiden und dadurch dass
der teig vegan es könnte jetzt natürlich
auch meine vegane haselnuss creme nehmen
dieses komplett wega natürlich auch
laktosefrei und schmeckt mindestens
genauso lecker wie die die nicht vegan
ist und viele sagen auch man merkt gar
nicht dass der iran ist schmeckt so
richtig wie seine milch creme und davon
gebe ich jetzt auch was in oder auf
meinen tag besser gesagt und dann habe
ich natürlich auch die vegane variante
und später wenn ich es sowieso im shop
verteilen haben wir auch einige veganer
und die können auch mal probieren
[Musik]
ich packte jetzt immer so ungefähr acht
neun bomben auf einem backblech das habe
ich mit backpapier ausgelegt und es ist
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir den backofen
vorheizen versuch richtig volle power
also nehmt euch da wirklich die zeit für
der sollte schön auf temperatur seien
220 grad ober und unterhitze und dann
brauchen sie auf der unteren einschub
leiste wirklich nur so sieben minuten
die dürfen auch nicht zu dunkel werben
bei mir zb einer sehr dunkel geworden
das liegt aber daran dass auch der
backofen nicht ganz gleichmäßig buck das
werdet ihr auch haben es ist gar kein
problem aber wir sollten wirklich noch
schön hell sein damit der teig richtig
schön knusprig und nicht zu trocken und
innen sollte es dann auch nicht zu heiß
werden
[Musik]
und jetzt mache ich weiter mit meinem
marmortisch man sehr gespannt wie der
gleich aussehen wird und das werde ich
jetzt auch noch mal einen teil meine
teiglinge wegen übrigens für euch sollte
kleiner hinweis circa 20 gramm damit ihr
euch daran ein bisschen orientieren
können und raus bekommen habe ich gerade
16 teile und jetzt werde ich wieder 16
einteilen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt bei mir im shop der haben
wir es dort hinten in der packstation
und arbeitet gerade und ich wollte euch
mal zeigen sie mir hier schön in so eine
aufgeschaltete dose gepackt und jetzt
werde ich die bomben noch einmal in die
mikrowelle geben aber auch wenn ich also
15 20 sekunden einfach damit nochmals
haben wird und damit in die creme auch
noch mal dass sich flüssig wird und dann
zeige ich euch überraschen den haben sie
damit und zeigt euch dann in testet
[Musik]
hallo mitarbeiter des monat hallo nicht
das machen wir gerne kerne
also ich weiß achim stocker ist ja habe
ich viel geldhauses problem besser warm
[Musik]
ich finde jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
reiten können
einen geschmack noch mehr
weil
ich sage auch die machen richtig du
kannst du bis sechs stück auf einmal in
österreich
die schlechte aufnahme leute also leute
ehrlich das müsst ihr unbedingt
nachmachen das schmeckt heftig stecker
und alle diejenigen die das mein türkei
probiert haben ich weiß dass zur seite
das ist viel kleiner
[Musik]
das